another thing that i wanted to talk
about that was i wanted your opinion on
is that you were mentioning about you
know how you could say anything you
wanted to say in the comments and people
give a [ __ ]
in the uk did you see that they were
trying to get a law passed to like um
have it so that you need your like
public id to sign up to websites oh yeah
yeah
you could be like criminally charged if
you bully people online that was they
were trying to get that in the uk yeah
really that was actually a uh there was
a similar law like that in japan
actually years ago really um of uh
with 2chan
when 2chan was a thing um well i mean
when 2chan started to become a thing and
it started to get really serious is that
there there were many politicians that
were like if you want to use 2chan or
any kind of message board in japan you
need to put like your real identity and
get like properly id and scanners
yeah right exactly and uh i remember the
the founder of 2chan hiroyuki uh he went
on tv campaigning against it because he
was like that's just censoring like that
goes completely against the whole point
of sites like 2chan and just internet
and stuff like that and he he basically
i mean he was ruthless about it he
basically said if you can't handle it
then [ __ ] off you know which you know in
some aspects yes i agree with but in
other aspects i do see like especially
nowadays with kids who
can get asked no sure whatsoever right
they just think they can go ham on
everything without thinking of any
repercussions right yeah it's it's weird
man because uh you know obviously i i
can i can sympathize with people who
have had some really awful experiences
with public shaming and stuff like that
and it's really you know
i imagine it's not easy to deal with
yeah but on the other hand it's like all
right i get it
but come on anonymity is an amazing
thing and it empowers a lot of people
and you know it i feel like when you try
and take away anonymity from people it
disproportionately affects uh people who
are uh in worse positions you know um so
it's weird and also i thought okay so
let's say i have to make id to join
twitter in the uk brahms you boot up
that vpn and yeah go to america like i'm
not signing up with my idea are you
kidding me even if even as a public
figure i do not want to give my id to
like twitter like yeah i do not want to
do that but that's the last thing right
it's like anonymity is such a powerful
no do you not give need to give it for
verification
do you oh you do do
[Laughter]
we know who
connor i would never give up my id for
twitter i i would rather go to war jokes
but that tick mark though
put the verification that checkmark
don't enticing i can't wait for this
[ __ ] kirby enthusiasm
poorly aced things
literally took like five seconds
i meant not like
that's just like general user i get what
you mean though
it's stupid yeah no but that's the thing
is like i was saying like i think that's
what's so powerful about anonymity is
that i think true anonymity is so
difficult to achieve outside of the
internet
that's what makes it so powerful on the
internet because it's really the only
place on the planet where you can really
just be completely anonymous okay and do
and say [ __ ] you know i mean i i hate
the fact that some people are just
really abhorrent to me online sometimes
for no particular reason but i'm not
going to sit there and be like you know
people that means nobody gets to enjoy
the freedoms of the internet
and there's a lot of countries where
that's like life or death that anonymity
is very important like i would never
ever want to take that away for a blue
check mark just just
just yeah just imagine i can just
imagine someone's like talking [ __ ] to
me right like quote retweeting saying
something mean and i'm like what's your
identity show me how old you are where
do you live let me contact the internet
police oh wait that's the thing now the
cyber police so what are you going to do
go to prison because you [ __ ] ratioed
someone like what like what's
how are you going to do calling on my
cyber lawyer how are you going to define
bullying like that yeah this is the
reason why bullying laws have like never
ever worked because it's like how the
[ __ ] do you define bullying like one
man's insult is another men's like pepe
left like i don't know man it's like
it's i don't know you know what some
people may find funny and jovial other
people may find like [ __ ] deeply
offensive yeah yeah yeah but half the
time if you're super offended by
something like that it's probably on you
yeah no i get like the whole thing of
like you know cyber thing is like a a
real thing and you know it's not just a
simple matter of oh just just close your
eyes or you know just get off the
internet just just don't look right yeah
just don't look at it right like you
know it's it's i obviously it's
obviously not that simple but you know
at the same time it's like yeah you know
people's thresholds of what they're
offended by is very different i mean i i
don't think there is a perfect solution
because yes i do think people need to
like chill out online and i i don't
agree that the right solution to that is
by monitoring everyone and uh kind of
having to make it uh make it like a
default thing where you have to give up
your id and your you know your anonymity
and stuff like that yeah they already
have that [ __ ] anyway why do they need
it yeah they
already know that
the government doesn't [ __ ] already
know everything about it yeah right yeah
they're tracking you every day they know
what hentai i'm watching they don't
actually need to put cookies on my
browser i'll straight up tell them bro
leave me alone i know yeah so i i i
guess i guess my my philosophy behind it
is just like to keep your mans in check
you know if you do see if you do see
someone acting like a [ __ ] then you
know it's it's kind of a social thing
just say oi stop being a [ __ ] stop
being a [ __ ] [ __ ] yeah
it's not hard
all right i need to piss quickly shot
even this man needs to piss every two
differently
half of the bottle one thing that pisses
me off about this debate right yeah is
that they always just piggyback off of
like really tragic events to push their
agenda of we need we need i don't know
we can't have anonymity yeah people are
dying out here from anonymity it's like
you're just you're just using like
really tragic events to push your agenda
how are people dying for a man
oh yeah you know like cyberbullying
people you know like uh oh
there's a very famous one with the
terrace house school oh yes oh yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah um but yeah i remember
that that whole started a debate as well
yeah yeah and then i know that
with the uh like english football
players people being like super racist
towards them i was really [ __ ] up and
then that's when it the debate really
started going and it's like yeah this is
this is horrible but like the bigger
picture is like they're trying to like
take away
your that's amazing freedom like freedom
we already resigned so much why are you
just like giving it to them like yeah
take it please please
and it's like you know
like people are still racist whether
they're anonymous or not right yeah so
it's like
i think that i feel like we're not we're
not getting to the root of the problem
well go to the facebook groups
it's literally got their whole family
tree on there and they're saying the
worst [ __ ] they're gonna change anything
it's like oh cool my uncle just joined
the kkk fan club on facebook it's like
great it's not anonymous it's still
racist you know but like that's the
problem right it's like i feel yeah as
you said it's like they're using the
anonymous excuse to
cover up the actual root of the problem
right it's like the root of the problem
is not this anonymous person saying
racist [ __ ] it's the problem that that
person is a racist man sometimes i wish
one of us was just like [ __ ] weird as
[ __ ] so we could just like so you you
would just be like yeah dude i'm gonna
i'm like anti-vaxx 5g
so that we'd have like more interesting
things more interesting just because i'm
like why why are you going to be [ __ ]
sensible [ __ ] stop agreeing with me
we have common sense god [ __ ] doubt
it god [ __ ] dead
like a conspiracy why are you not like
part of the cake again
we were roasting
by alex jones
just balance it out
why are you going to be so damn sensible
all the time
oh my god but i mean like like i guess i
guess this is like peeking back picking
back on like the discussion we had last
week about uh
about you know about hearing what the
other side has to say right and i can't
remember exactly what i said to like end
of the podcast um because that's that's
how it is on trash chase podcast but uh
i do remember i do remember thinking one
thing i actually like doing is uh
actually like i like going we follow
people from the other side yeah we're
like going we like following people
from the other side just to see
what they're thinking or what their
argument is so one thing i actually like
doing is i like to see what some of like
say the craziest people are thinking
right just just so
not not because i want to believe them
just because i'm like
so curious about how they got to that
point right so one thing i like doing is
just listening to like flat earthers
defend defend what they believe defend
flat earth right actually not weird the
flat earth like online presences though
like there's so much like anti-semitism
there as well likely yeah yeah it's
really bizarre i did i did see a video
of a guy i think it was a vice dog
inventor of a guy going like a flat
earth convention maybe it's all gas no
breaks no it wasn't all gas no brakes it
was like a proper like documentary
going to a flat earth convention and it
was just yeah like i i couldn't even get
mad at the stuff they were talking about
because like anyone can anyone sensible
can tell you that what they're saying is
just doo doo kaka but
but like at the same time i was so
fascinated being like i genuinely wonder
how you got to this point yeah like not
even to like hate just like i'm just
like as cure like psychologically i'm
just curious yeah exactly what you had
to input and what you had to be
surrounded by in order for you to truly
believe
that the earth is flat yeah and like
looking into it and seeing like so many
different like [ __ ] uh [ __ ] flat
earthers and different videos about flat
earthers i'm just like oh a lot of this
just comes down to like a core distrust
of the government and a system like a
systematic distrust it's it's so much of
a distrust that they would rather
believe that the earth is flat than
believe what scientists say and what's
like what an organization like nasa says
which is like it's it's it's it's
fascinating and it's also hilarious that
to them nasa is basically just like the
[ __ ] illuminati
the problem is that we've actually had
real conspiracies happen so so people
just have like this weird confidence
that like it's happened before we've
proven that these some conspiracy
theories have happened yeah you know it
has happened in the past and so they get
like weirdly confident about it i think
in a sense from some stuff like that i
don't know i don't have this mindset i
like this is stuff like that is so far
from where i have a view of things yeah
i can't even begin to like
i can't i can't even begin to like dive
in no i can't i don't even understand
like how like and i think this is the
problem is that like
the like a lot of people just cannot
even remotely see where they're coming
from yeah yeah like with politics
sometimes you know you can kind of
understand right you just you disagree
but you can somewhat understand very
rarely yeah online but um you know but
with stuff like this it's so in like to
us it's so insane right yeah i don't
even know how to begin to be like yeah
you have a point i don't even know how
to how to entertain it i don't know yeah
i don't know
to me it's just like it's not about
entertaining it's just like i'm just
genuinely curious i'm just like
genuinely i'm like no not even trying to
change your mind i'm just like genuinely
how the [ __ ] did you get to this point
for me it's not even like a young age i
don't know i don't know yeah
but for me it's not even the point of
like me trying to figure out if i can
even say yeah you've got a point yeah
for me the mo all the time it's just go
on
i'm listening but i'm not going to like
taking anything i am just listening to
you because my whole life growing up
right i've never met anyone who's been
into like really bizarre stuff like that
well not openly yeah no so it's kind of
like weird for me because i'm like okay
i've had my i've experienced my whole
life like i understand now as an adult i
can kind of have my own circles but i
wonder why it's like growing up and like
university and stuff like that how i've
never really met anyone who's been very
hardcore into this at least in the uk i
don't know about elsewhere i think it's
maybe because they kind of come down a
dozen right like i feel it's like they
they make it i think media just makes it
so out that there is this like massive
large community that our flat earth is
like it's getting bigger i think it is
getting bigger it is it is getting
better i still don't think it's to the
point where it's become noticeably
bigger you know like i still think at
the end of the day it is still very very
tiny population that actually is
involved
it's hard it's hard to say right it's
hard at least at least it's to the point
where you know they're willing to go to
a convention about it i mean it
definitely feels like it's getting
bigger right like before before i
remember hearing about flat earthers and
i would just laugh like that was just
like an urban legend or something and
then you realize that people like this
actually exist
and uh
they they're getting they're getting
more of like a
they're getting larger because they have
a platform to be able to get larger on
which is you know the internet i mean i
guess the fact that an entire convention
exists about it exactly right this is
the thing that i i hate about it as well
is i hate talking about it because the
more you talk about it the more you like
give them a a strange sense of
confidence yeah because we're so sure
because we're so sure that we know that
the earth is round yeah we know that
yeah
and it's weird the fact that we because
i feel like the fact that we almost keep
talking about it and being like yeah we
know we know it is you're dumb you're
dumb yeah they they think i was just
adding to the conspiracy because you're
you know it's it's what i've been told
that everyone's going to tell me i'm
stupid and that everyone's against me
yeah yeah and so it's this weird thing
where i'm like all right we just never
gave them any any kind of credence
before we never paid any attention to
them hundreds of years ago when they
said this or hundreds of years they
think it was flat but you know like not
1930s what i don't know
give [ __ ] [ __ ] they were like yeah
whatever you're crazy have a nice day
yeah yeah i wouldn't talk about it right
but now because it's so well
disgusted and so well uh spoke about i
feel like it almost lends itself more
confidence on more avenues people who
are susceptible to stuff like that to
get into it yeah yeah i feel the more we
talk about it the more it just gives the
that group of people power right
that's why i always come from a place of
i want to understand the other side
because like i feel like do you
understand i know i i do i do kind of
understand where they where do you think
it comes from where do you think it
comes from how does a person get to like
believing in something like that well a
lot of it like i said is such a a
distrust of the system that is this
yeah where does the distrust of the
system come from there's i mean there's
a lot of things that um that it could
come from a big thing is religion as
well you know
a lot of a lot of flat earthers you you
see are you know very very religious
people not to say that religion is the
core cause of this you know
i i i have to [ __ ]
i have preface
preface that as someone who is religious
myself
but you know it's it's it's people who
are
who
this who distrust like distrust the
government distrust organizations so
much that conspiracy theories to them
seem more palpitable
than what everyone else is telling them
because they've been they've grown up in
an environment where it's like don't
trust what everyone else is telling you
and because everyone around them is
telling them that they're wrong that
only like you said strengthens their
views and looks for more reasons for
them to like believe in the system right
believe believe and believe and
believe what they've come to believe i'm
sympathetic in some ways i feel like
even though yeah you're right like they
they don't trust in the systems almost
because i think in a lot of ways the
systems have failed them like systems
that uh you know we take for granted
because you know we had good upbringings
you know we were very lucky that we
had very
ordinary quote-unquote lives and yeah
had a good education i suppose and i
feel like if you if you are unfortunate
enough to just kind of
not have access to a lot of things and
you know you're told that certain
organizations or things will protect you
or just learn from these things and you
don't and they let you down i can
understand why you'd almost
not trust these systems yeah yeah
supposed to be put in place to help you
yeah um so yeah it's it's tough though
yeah which is why like
which is like i like doing [ __ ] like
this because especially on the internet
with how online discourses like like i
said last week a lot of people
people would know what they stand
against but very few people know what
they stand for and that's just because
it's so much easier to like prove
someone else wrong than prove yourself
right right so it's it's it's come to a
point where
i i want to understand the other side
because one thing that's missing from a
lot of online discourse and online
discussions is people trying to [ __ ]
understand each other everyone's just
trying to prove each other wrong rather
than having a health having a healthy
debate and i think having an
understanding of the other side is the
first step to having a healthy debate
and
so if i can understand flat earthers
then who the [ __ ] on the internet can't
i understand and that's why i
and that's why i do this [ __ ] if open
conversations were normalized on the
internet we'd all be driving flying cars
you know like yeah yeah exactly yes but
unfortunately we are still on the ground
yeah yeah
it's a hard
[Laughter]